SPEAKER: One notification
trying to do everything,
or 10 notifications
trying to take over
the whole notification chain?
How about the best
of both worlds
with bundled notifications?
By bundling notifications
into a group,
users will be able to act
on the entire group at once
or expand the group
to see and act
on the individual
notifications in the group.
Now I've talked about
building a great notification
with notification
so let's assume
you've already built great
individual notifications.
If users aren't getting
any benefit, such as more
information or actions
out of expanding
individual notifications, you
should work on that first.
But once you have awesome
individual notifications,
bundling similar
notifications together
is done by calling set
group for each notification.
By default,
notifications will be
ordered by when they're posted.
But you can override
it with set sort key
and the system will sort
by that value instead.
There's one other part to
bundled notifications, though--
a summary notification.
On Marshmallow and
lower phones and tablets
that don't directly support
bundled notifications.
Only the summary notification
will be displayed.
So make sure it's also
a great notification.
The inbox style is a great
candidate for these summary
notifications to give users
a quick overview of all
the notifications they have.
Just make sure to call Set
Group with that same key,
and then call Set Group
Summary true to denote
that notification as your
summary notification.
Note, you'll still want to
build a summary notification
on devices that support
bundled notifications,
as that's used
indirectly by the system
to extract information
for the header
when the group is collapsed.
Now, if you're thinking to
yourself, ugh, add Set Group
and set Group Summary,
sounds like a lot of work.
There's two additional
reasons you should really
bundle your notifications.
For one, there's
a lot of users out
there already with devices that
support bundled notifications.
Every Android Wear user that's
right, by using this API,
you're going to be making a
great experience for every one
of those users as well, even if
they're still using a Kit Kat
device.
Secondly, API 24
and higher devices
are going to bundle your
notifications for you,
if you post four or more
without any grouping.
And you probably
have a better idea
of what bundles and
summary notification
make sense for your own app.
So if you're posting
multiple notifications,
use bundled notifications to
help you build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]